IT WAS THATCHER DEMKO WHO
YESTERDAY TOOK A MAINTENANCE DAE
LIGHTNING, THI ABBOTSFORD CANUCH
IT IS MOTTE, AFTFT HE HAS REALLE
ON.
ALONG THE IN A GOOD MOOD,
YOU KNEW IT WOULD
AND NOW A WHIHI FINISHED LAST T.
AND DISCOMFORT 50/50
WRISTER, BLOCKERED TO GARLAND.
CENTRES!
MILLER.
THAT ONE OFF OF TO CHALLENGE FOR
OFFSIDE.
GOODK.
STAMKOS, HIGH.
HE ICKS GOT BACK INTO IT AND
ON THE SHOT CLOCK AS WELL. NOW,D
THEN DOWN THE ICE AND IT WILL BE
AN ICINGNG 0-1 ON THE
POWER PLAY AND TAMPA NOW O FOR
THEIRTO TAKE ADVANTAGE, McDONAGS
S
TO GO IN THE POWER PLAY, MILLER
FAKING THAT SHOT NOW
IN.
AND A PASS FOR HUGHES, BROKEN UP
AND PODKOLZIN,
>> John S.: MILLER ABLE TO GET
AROUND AND G
THAT PUCK, MYERS NOW ON HIM.KHAE
AHEAD, HIGHMORE, HANGS ONTO
THE PUCK.
>> John G.: TALKING ABOUT
KUCHEROV AND STAMKOS, EDS GONE N
THE PENALTY TO LUKE SCHENN AND
NOW IT IS KILLOLO FOR AN OFFENSY
THERE,E, THE SIDE AND
MILLER, OH, TOOK A LOOK SIX TAR.
AND GARLANDTRE, TIPS IT
IN., PUCK ACROSS, GARLANDND